allegations of rape in the australian
parliament have resulted in mass
demonstrations across the country
thousands have rallied against misogyny
and workplace cultures that are
dangerous to women
in the capital canberra people gathered
to protest as part of the march for
justice
the movement is demanding an
investigation into sexual misconduct in
parliament house
prime minister scott morrison is under
pressure over his handling
of a series of rape allegations against
politicians and
staffers
we are now joined from melbourne by
sonia turpstar a politician for
australia's centre-left
labour party in the eastern state of
victoria it's only
thousands of women on the streets of
more than 40 cities and towns
what's led to this yeah well
as you were discussing earlier the um
there's been some very serious
allegations of
not only sexual harassment in our
federal parliament but also
allegations of rape so these are very
very serious allegations and many women
across australia and their supporters
and allies are very angry and took to
the streets today
to protest against that australia's
prime minister scott morrison made
a statement about the protests in
parliament today
uh let's listen to what he had to say so
i acknowledge the frustration and share
the disappointment
of what has yet not been achieved mr
speaker
members mr speaker those who gather
outside this place today
an invitation was offered to them for a
meeting with me here today
a good faith action mr speaker but i
respect
their right of organizers to choose not
to meet
uh sonia your party is of course an
opposition federally to the prime
ministers how would you rate the
government's
uh handling of this well
um if it's anything to go by the
reaction across
um australia today by women it's an
appalling response
really it's not good enough um women
were calling for the prime minister to
come
out from parliament house and to meet
them on the forecourt which he refused
to do
and it's it's really is a provocative
and inflammatory response and and it's
just not good enough it's simply not
good enough
so almost a decade ago former mp
julia gillard made a famous speech in
parliament against sexism and misogyny
it has really
nothing changed in australian politics
since then
yeah look it's it's interesting in this
speech by our former prime minister
julia gillard really did galvanize
a lot of women um because it really
resonated and i think
many years have passed since that speech
but i think that certainly what's
happened in the last
few weeks has really meant for a lot of
women that we can say that really things
haven't really changed and women are
calling for
much a much deeper commitment by our
federal politicians to really stamp out
sexism misogyny
sexual harassment in the workplace and
of course a very serious
allegations involving rape women have
had enough it's simply not good enough
and and women all around australia are
calling on our federal politicians to do
more
and to take our concerns very seriously
so it does seem that things really
haven't changed
thank you very much sonia terpstra
politician for australia center-left
labour party
in the eastern state of victoria
you